Je nous ai alloué huit dollars chacun
par repas, il semble donc que vous puissiez obtenir
l'une des salades ou un costume
désolé, je suis rapide la soupe aux tomates pour moi
s'il vous plaît ça va le faire je vais prendre une
dalle complète  sur les sacs de bébé et je vais
prendre ça avec de la purée de taters hushpuppies
et je vais prendre un je vais prendre un
thé sucré je te demande de manger moins de nourriture
qu'est-ce qui ne va pas avec toi c'est une
belle femme que je n'aime pas  je ne mange pas non il a
raison non j'ai pris un peu de
poids à cause de tout le stress Walters
un pompier oh ouais mais ça va même je suis
assez intense elle s'en fout de l'
accident de l'année dernière il s'est blessé les
parties masculines  ils sont juste déchiquetés là-bas
et maintenant il ne peut pas travailler il veut combattre les
incendies et il veut un morceau le mettre en place le
battre je sais que tu le fais mais il ne peut pas
il apporte trop tôt